♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est dans cette immense
cuvette à Thacker Pass,
formée par un volcan il y a
des millions d'années,
qu'Edward Bartell détient
des terres où viennent brouter
ses 500 vaches.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est dans cette même cuvette,
incrusté dans le sol argileux,
que repose un des plus
importants gisements de lithium
en Amérique du Nord.
Surnommé l'or blanc, le lithium
est essentiel au fonctionnement
des cellulaires, des panneaux
solaires, des éoliennes, mais
il est surtout à la voiture
électrique ce que le pétrole
est à la voiture à essence.
- We are going to start
by mining the clay deposit.
- Lithium America, une compagnie
canadienne, veut construire,
juste à côté des terres
d'Edward, la plus grande mine
de lithium à ciel ouvert
en Amérique du Nord, accompagnée
d'une gigantesque usine
pour transformer le minerai
en carbonate de lithium.
À plein régime, la mine
permettra de construire
1 million de voitures
électriques chaque année.
♪ ♪ ♪
Washington a déjà octroyé
le permis d'exploitation fédéral
au projet, car pour embarquer
dans le train climatique,
la moitié des véhicules vendus
aux États-Unis devront être
électriques d'ici 10 ans,
prévient le gouvernement.
Actuellement, les plus grands
producteurs de lithium sont
le Chili, l'Argentine,
l'Australie. Le lithium est
ensuite envoyé en Chine, le pays
qui domine la transformation
de la matière première.
Produisant à peine 1 %
du lithium dans le monde,
les États-Unis avancent
à fond de train.
Vite... trop vite, selon
Edward Bartell, qui anticipe
un désastre.
Car des installations de
la sorte requièrent de grandes
quantités d'eau et de produits
chimiques.
Lithium America assure prendre
tous les moyens pour protéger
l'environnement.
Edward Bartell n'y croit pas
et, dans l'espoir de freiner
le projet, poursuit en justice
le Bureau de la gestion
des terres publiques.
Edward n'est pas le seul
à s'opposer à la mine.
Max Wilbert milite activement.
L'écologiste campe plusieurs
jours par mois sur le site
en signe de protestation.
Avec un ami avocat,
ils travaillent avec
des communautés autochtones
pour qui le site est sacré,
comme celle de Reno-Sparks.
Thacker Pass aurait été le
théâtre d'un massacre orchestré
par la cavalerie américaine
en 1865; y reposeraient donc
sur ces terres les dépouilles
de leurs ancêtres autochtones.
Eux aussi poursuivent
le gouvernement en justice.
Puis, il y a des gens comme
Gina Amato. Elle est la porte-
parole des 200 résidents de la
communauté agricole d'Orovada,
située à moins de 30 km
de Thacker Pass.
Rares sont ceux ici qui veulent
de cette mine à Orovada.
Mais ici, on sait qu'un jour ou
l'autre, on n'y échappera pas.
Il vaut mieux, donc, négocier
pour faire avancer les intérêts
de la communauté, tout en jouant
au chien de garde.
Lithium America s'est engagée
à construire une nouvelle école
pour remplacer celle-ci,
vétuste, et promet des emplois
payants à la mine; puis, payera
un professionnel au choix de
la communauté pour qu'il repasse
au peigne fin les études
d'impact environnemental.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un peu plus loin, à Winnemucca,
le maire de la municipalité
de 8000 résidents, lui,
approuve le projet de mine.
Et Richard Stone répond ceci
à ceux qui s'inquiètent
pour l'environnement.
Une réponse un peu trop
simpliste aux yeux
de Gina Amato.
L'environnement contre
l'environnement, donc :
un combat inégal que Max Wilbert
est quand même déterminé
à mener.
Un espoir auquel s'accroche
Edward, sans toutefois se faire
d'illusions.
♪ ♪ ♪